Well. Well, well go to your mom's house.
We're rolling. And it's, it's
funny that you mentioned that, uh,
our very special guest today is the
delightful and I'm tremendously help you
still feel that way. Okay, go. I'm done by
four. And um, just, just as an absolutely.
Uh,
I would say tremendously tempting torso.
Dr Drew the body Penske
many years ago,
we got a peek behind the curtain of your
upper body and I gotta say I was the
long time ago. You mask that. You
deliberately do that, don't you?
On on TV,
like not anymore.
Seen Him. And I was like, what?
Because I'd seen you for a while on TV.
Then I see you shirtless, uh, at a
pool and I'm like, what the fuck?
This guy must have had a towel
around my waist or something.
I just had my provider.
I mean,
was that something that you got into
a long time ago? Weightlifting? Yeah,
long time ago when I was 14. And you'd
say you did have almost never stopped.
It's weird, but now it's become
my, my, like my meditation now.
Now I get weight lifting. I do. Well,
it's not even when it barely weight
lifting anymore, but it's, it's I lift.
I listened to a podcast
and I just sit and I just,
I go into it like a meditative state.
And does your wife talk
during this podcast?
Just he mesmerized by his body.
And O eight Tom and I were
living in the rampart division.
We were engaged in a
one bedroom apartment,
but celebrity rehab was
the glue to our marriage.
When you say like we're huge fans,
they seen every episode.
We were obsessed with you.
I've listened to you since love
lions since the poor man days.
That's kind of weird.
CHARAC crazy boy.
I can we go back to his body?
I want to know.
So one thing that stood out the
most is that it really felt like a,
nobody would know that you
were this in shape dude,
which is kind of like
an interesting thing.
A lot of people that are really into
fitness would like make an effort to go.
Like,
I'm going to show everybody and I'm
going to show him because I've earned it.
Which then you go like, oh
yeah, that's a good point.
But I feel like none of the clothes you
wear on celebrity rehab or any need to
flaunt
it takes away from you.
Took credibility as you'll be aware.
Early on in my career as a physician,
I always thought that be kind of weird.
I remember I used to wear green
sometimes when people, where did you,
where did you have to shop for?
Like oversized shirts?
Is that what was that party?
No,
but I always had problem with
shoulder and arm fit. I've always had,
it's just how I'm constructed and if I
weight lift, this stuff gets big here.
Yeah. And I remember nurse coming to
goes, that's that doctor arms thought,
oh that's weird to cover that
all up. Okay, so you wait,
you're saying you were Green Greens,
you know, surgical grains and in your,
you looked, excuse me, ripped and I
didn't look like a rest. Everybody else.
So I was like, oh, that's weird. I
feel like after, I mean I'm probably,
I'm probably the one that just outdid you,
but I think for the audience you're going
to have to post some some thirst trap.
I will lose about 10 pounds first.
My wife's of why we were in Mexico last
week and my wife posted a picture of the
two of us in a bay that she, she's
biotic, she has some insane jeans.
It's all just natural with her.
And uh, God bless her and uh,
or bless her heart as they say bless.
Uh,
and she took this picture. I'm like,
for God's sake, at least make me sit up.
I look like,
I'm like,
I look like I like ms
or als and this barrier.
It's a longstanding thing where it's
like you take a picture of me, I'm,
I'm reviewing first
right of refusal is nice
outfit and make sure he doesn't look
homeless or we're good. Yeah. Yeah.
You need that cause the man,
you don't think about that now you
got to make sure somebody loves you.
That's what we say when we say a sad guy
out there that's dressed all fucked up.
It's got, the wife doesn't love
it. You need love in your life.
Somebody who's a
celebrity, celebrity doctor.
But yeah, it's weird.
I'll tell you the off the top of
a long story, but we were not,
we were talking about stern
before we wrap up show, which is,
which is these days equally as, as
an honor, I've sat in the real seat,
the Howard interview. See that's
reserved now for like Gwyneth Paltrow.
Yeah, no one gets in there
anymore. But when I was in there,
I will tell you it's very interesting
seat to sit in because he,
it's like he hypnotizes you
like you're in a truth serum.
He just got to go with them.
It just got to become abject honesty and
he just has this amazing way of just,
just getting into such gifted
and he follows his nose.
It's from all his strongest therapy and
stuff and all his, all the tributes him.
But I was a, this is the story
I wanted to tell you. I was, um,
my mother just started recently. It
should very advanced age. No, no.
Certain life should be celebrated when
if they live into your 90 [inaudible] you
had a good life. No is
fine, everything is fine,
but I was cleaning up her basement.
I found a stack of my old mad magazines,
1960 to 1972 I'll be a whole
cache of them and I thought, oh
my God, Howard loves these things.
I bet he loved this.
So I went and I wrapped it up in butcher
paper and I went and got bought a car.
They'd wrote a handwritten note and I
gave it to him and I was just totally
crest fallen when,
when the next day on the radio,
he was just going off about why would
somebody send anyone this piece of shit is
crashing garbage, the spider
web. He goes, he goes,
I'm going to wipe my ass and send him.
I use toilet paper.
He went off for 20 minutes about it
and then it came up again. Today.
Went off again today because
apparently I brought up with Corolla.
I'm the Adam [inaudible] podcast and
a, and I told him I was, you know,
I was looking forward to him hearing that,
hearing that he liked this gift and I
was just, just, it stung pretty bad.
Of course it wouldn't be good radio if
it didn't sting right. It had to be real.
And uh, he, he would have been a
mentioned became a 20 minute bid.
That's his genius. Right, right.
Uh, but it stung. It still stung.
It's so Adam called Howard
told them that I was unhappy.
So that came up on the radio today.
So there you go
and you're going and Gary was talking
about the area that sent me a note.
Listen to this Gary,
something that tonight he got a text from
somebody demanding an apology claiming
to be me. And I was like, Hey,
no, no, no, no, no. A million
miles from that. I'm fine.
I understand you're going to hurt
though. If it didn't hurt, I also know,
yes I was, I was crestfallen. I
was stung. I was disappointed.
But then I thought to myself,
if it didn't sting,
this would not have been good radio. It
just has to be that kind of truth. You,
you really just worried him to be like, I
wouldn't have to go. I'm like, yes, yes,
I thought of it. And really
20 a moment. Then again,
it wouldn't be Howard stern if he wouldn't
take something awesome and make it a
neurotic. Absolutely. And
gear. And Gary just goes,
I sent him an email or your gear
goes walking to why we're all good.
No good deed goes unpunished right here.
And I thought that's true.
In 30 years he's been dealing with
that every little thing. He's like,
I thought you'd like that stern boss.
They're always talking about,
that's the only place where
if you do something good,
it gets turned into. Whoops,
hang. Just text me. Wow. That's from Gary.
Pertaining to be demanding an apology.
That's crazy. It's crazy. That's crazy.
So the long story, it is crazy talk.
Um, the, the long story
is, uh, I, let's see,
I think it take it all the way back.
I was a third year medical,
fourth year medical student and I was
here in Pasadena living less than a block
from what was then k rock k rock back
in the day when you were 13 was this
little shit hole or like a dental office.
It was really a horrible,
like I wish we'd taken video and
stuff of it cause it was never will be
recreated this, this kind of
an environment and um, they're,
they're kind of working on a
documentary on it right now. So yeah.
Then they're interviewing everybody and
Ron of course.
And so, so it was, I would just,
I was really getting frustrated with
music and people started talking about the
station and I, oh, it's up the street.
How interesting. I started listening,
getting gibbering got
kind of excited about it.
People I knew that live nearby where
it's starting to go over there and new
people. And this guy calls me that it was
hanging out over there and he goes, hey,
they've got the show in
the middle of the night.
Apparently two guys were just taking calls
about relationships and their program
director told them they need to make
it a community service show. Right.
They needed to make,
cause they'd had be service hours.
So they gave them midnight Sunday night
to 3:00 AM Monday morning. Fantastic.
And uh, but then they're trying to
figure out how to make community service.
And my friend, I guess suggested me or
I'm in medical school, so maybe I could,
and they call me and they go, Hey,
I'll tell you what I want you,
I want you to do a segment called
ask a surgeon. You'll use big words.
It'll be really fun. What are you talking?
You know, so they finally, long story,
they got me in there. I brought
my textbooks at my gynecology tax,
my infectious disease textbooks.
I literally carried textbooks up.
They're really not having any
idea what I was getting into,
but I was freaked out.
And, uh, Lo and behold,
I heard these just amazing things coming.
Being presented to was the poor man and
the Swedish Eagle in the middle of the
night. And Scott Mason,
they'll still around. Yeah.
It's all in the series and I thought,
uh, I should, I should come back and,
and what stucked out,
what really stunned me was I was dealing
with a lot of aids patients that and
continued to the next five year thing,
tons of aids work and no one was
talking to young people about it.
We'd just been to the sexual
revolution where the adults,
the perpetrator that never contemplated
that adolescents would engage the
sexuality. Sure. Condoms were behind the
counter yet ask the pharmacist for them.
Now the term safe sex hadn't been coined
yet. People were not talking to adults,
young adults about this at all, about
what was going on. I was like, Dude,
so I was 24 I was like, Hey, I
know what 19 nine year olds are up.
18 nine year olds are up to we
gotta we gotta talk about this.
And no one had ever heard,
in fact,
we just were transitioning from
calling it grids to eight. We're, yeah,
we're calling it aids then,
but we weren't calling it,
we had an identified the
virus yet. Wow. We had,
we had just were getting
htlv three remember that?
So the GLB three did you suggest talking
about this on the air is that they came
to him and so I just came in there as to
do as little segment for Amenity Eagle
and I was like, oh my God, this is like,
I got to keep coming
back and said hang out.
So it's sort of hang out in the hall
and if something came up or if I was not
calling and I'd stay there
for like midnight to two or
something to hang around.
And finally I was started sitting at the
table with them and being a part of it.
And it was, he was, became a parent to
meet early that it was a two man thing,
like yeah,
sort of a parent child kind of conflict
thing or funny and strange and um,
and I just thought it was important and
I have for 10 years I was doing what I
thought was one night a week
community service. We really,
I thought it was just interesting.
It was like my social hour,
I beat her sick people.
We'd have guests in there.
And it was just interesting and fun that
my wife through there. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And uh, and after 10 years
of doing it one night a week,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
For free, for free.
They put it on five nights a week.
Cause I remember what happened was,
I remember they, they, they got to re we,
they moved it to like 10 to one at
that point because they kept people.
It's still had a buzz around. It was late
cause it was sexual conduct. Yeah. Yeah.
Years. I mean you had finished your
internship and residency. Yeah.
Oh yeah. I was on practicing and
stuff. General General Medicine.
But I was also doing at that point,
let me think about this.
80,
late eighties,
I was doing running the medical
services in a psychiatric hospital.
So I was also doing,
I was doing an acute care inpatient thing.
I was doing medical services,
a psychiatric hospital and then an
outpatient medical deal. And um,
but it was a lot, I was way
work on two podcasts a week. No,
I was away. Workoholism like sick
workaholic or like bad, bad, bad.
Uh, and um, in 91,
so now it was literally,
I guess it was eight years now.
So it was eight years of five nights,
10 nights, one night a week. They,
they got a rating book on this show.
They don't do the weightings book.
Normally I had to ask for it or pay
for it. And I'll never forget this.
We got a 28 share.
What this is like,
is it a market where if you get
a 0.3 are doing great. And I,
I remember I called the program
director, I go, look, I'm,
I don't really know much about this,
but I think we're all participating in
something here. I didn't really know,
but 20 it seems like crazy to me.
He goes, I'll never forget this.
It was [inaudible] who was the
general manager, Kerrick. He goes,
cause if I had any balls,
I put this on five nights a week,
that's what I'm going to do.
I'm gonna put it on five minutes a week.
And I thought, oh cause
I, you know, I was,
I was working from five in the morning
to 10 at night at that point to where
it's very severe and um,
and Susan immediately then got
pregnant with triplets, triplets.
And so she goes, she goes, if
you're out five nights a week,
it's not community service anymore.
You got to get pay.
So she sent me in to see somebody loved
me, sent me and I hadn't handled it.
Could you please, can I please get pay? I
can't even, we're having kids and stuff.
And that's where it all got
started from that first offer.
And I don't imagine it's going to be
crazy, but like was it a decent offer?
$50 a show
cause is show 91. Yeah. And but,
but,
but they sort of promised like we'll have
a real contract at this goes how long
does he stay at?
$50 a shot.
It didn't seem that long cause then it
got syndicated and seven started to get
paid a little bit, a
little bit of that. Uh,
and then in 95,
these television producers turned up
and I was doing with Ricky Rachman then
and these and they were like, what's
the TV show like? Aye. Aye. Aye.
Interesting. It's all, it was all
kind of an exploration for me.
It's like I still thought I was doing
kind of a community service cause there
was nowhere for it to talk to kids about
this stuff and I thought there was just
so much encouragement of bad,
unhealthy behavior at that. Well,
we're just going to be here and be this
advocate for decent behavior. And uh,
there's a long story there too. But
eventually, uh, Ricky bowed out,
he couldn't make a deal with them
and they turned to me and they go,
who do you want to do with this? And
I was like, I have no idea. I'm fine.
Just leave me alone to practice
medicine if you really want it.
I can do this on Friday afternoon
and Saturday afternoon and that's it.
Otherwise leave me alone. And I went out
running one day and I'm, I was in a spot,
remember the spot where
it was when I thought guy,
but that guy that does Mr Birch
them in the morning could do this.
We had met once before and I thought,
I bet that guy can do it. So they,
how much this many details to get into
all of this. But they brought him out,
they tested us, everyone seemed to like
it put us in a makeup booth and they go,
you guys work out your relationship. We'll
start filming in an hour. And I will,
and we filmed for like nine hours, the
pilot for love line that ended up on MTV,
which by the way at that point was
a fox show. Long story there too.
She got canceled and
then picked up by MTV.
Well Auntie Annie was I think a decent
home phone. Perfect subject matter.
I think it might have failed
the Fox. That's absolutely
right. And, uh, but, uh, one,
one sort of memory I have about that first
day of filming the pilot is our stage
manager,
Tracy came up just who she became our
stage manager that we went did it for like
five years.
And um,
and just with your partner there was
with Adam live TV knows this MTV and he
hadn't even started the radio yet. We
were just doing, doing this podcast,
this a pilot for the TV show.
And we started doing the TV show
before he came over to radio. And um,
and Terry, she goes, how many years
you guys were working together?
We looked at each other with a, we
met this morning and I thought, oh,
that must mean something significant.
Yeah.
I even think that probably Miss Chemistry.
I always wondered this
like without like knowing,
you know so much about the show,
but you being a doctor and having to,
you know,
think about the advice you're giving out,
whether it's being like healthy and
you know, ethically, right. Yeah.
Did you ever have those
moments even though,
you know it's entertainment where somebody
asks something and Adam being comedic
gives advice to your like
you cannot say constantly,
but yeah, I don't know what I mean.
Like not just in like, hey, no that's bad.
But I mean like where you
get serious about it. We let,
it was not so much without him because
he really had a pretty good instinct on
things, but Ricky and
format more, more of that.
And I actually got an almost almost in
a file and fight with Jon Favreau over
this. He was in fabric fabric
director, the director,
he had just done a swingers. Right. It
wasn't that a big breakout. That's right.
And he was the guest on Loveline the TV
show and this guy calls in and he was
clearly schizophrenia and
dangerously psychotic,
like in danger of self harm or
harming other people. And uh,
complaining about in a paranoid way about
people who are trying to make him take
his medication and fabric
goes, don't tell, don't let
anybody tell you what to do,
do not take those medicines. And I
went, Whoa, Whoa, you got to stop.
This is dangerous. This guy is actually
sick. Who Do you think you are? I'm like,
oh dude, don't go there when
you're talking to a sick person.
And we got into it and a yeah,
see that's the shit I want to see.
I want to watch that.
And then I had done in the next,
so we would film show up to show
after show we didn't know any better.
We should have six shows a day out
of my reach changing clothes and uh,
and the next year I
had a panic attack and,
and I had to leave the
stage cause I was like,
I didn't realize because I was still
upset from this fight with John and Adam
comes into my, my dress stream. He goes,
Hey, get the fuck get back out there.
If I have to spend one more
minute in this goddamn studio,
then I have to because of you. I'm going
to kick your ass, get gas in there.
He was like it. Ever since
then he's like, you see,
I cured your panic attacks anyway.
Oh my God.
So well that show love line there.
I mean the early the radio show taught
me everything about banks have anywhere
else to go. Yeah. And My,
my idea was the same in addition to being
willing to talk about aids and things
like that.
My naive notion that 24 when I
started doing was I wish I had,
if I had had something like this,
if I knew somebody with this fund of
knowledge that I know how have no have,
what would I want it to know?
And I retained that sort of naive posture
for about most of the way through the
run of that.
They've got a little more involved once,
but towards the end of the nineties
people were kind of more sophisticated.
I think they're getting information
from different sources and things.
And then the Internet just,
let's see out of it in entertainment,
because you live out here,
you're involved in entertainment and
you also know so much about, you know,
mental health is,
are,
are there more like actors and comics
and whatnot that are prone to mental
health issues. So, so,
so I told you I ran the
psychiatric medical service.
We'll then I transitioned over to running
their addiction services and I really,
a lot of my time was spent doing running
an addiction unit for 91 to 2011,
essentially. So 20 years
I ran a drug unit. Uh,
I used to hang out there for a long
time before I started running it because
then that's how I sort of
learned about it and stuff.
So it's about 25 years in
addiction medicine. And um,
slub your rehab came out of just somebody,
a really good producer named John
Irwin just came to me and said,
do you want to do this? I'm
like, wow, what a great way,
this would be really great to teach me
about this, but this cannot be done.
It's just not possible and you're,
you're, you're kidding yourself.
And he went to the hospitals and they've
looked him like, she gotta be nuts.
And we finally figured out,
I figured out a way you could do it,
which I took my team and I put
them on a residential facility.
I knew the director there. And he
wanted to do it. It's a long story,
but in the course of all this,
I'm a professor at sc
and the business school,
he's actually a behavioral
economist specialist.
And I put together a questionnaire.
He was interested in sort of the business
of a entertainment. And I, and I,
he and I had a conversation when
he's my neighbor and I said,
when you really shouldn't understand
the people that are the product,
the people that are the celebrities
and the mattress, and I said,
and then they're all sick.
I know they are because I've talked
to him every night and they have an
inordinate tendency, OTF trauma and
other things. And he goes, well,
let's test that because it
was not published anywhere.
So we sort of figured
out a way to do that.
We use something called the narcissistic
personality inventory and everybody
that came on love when filled
one out for two years. And so we,
so we collected 250 profiles
on people and it was, you know,
significant celebrities and reality,
a good mix of reality and
comedians and musicians and things.
And we analyzed it all have
malignant personally. No,
like that definitely did it take to that,
well the Melinda was the female reality
show group. They were laughing at them,
a liga personality ran Tom the
politicians. We wanted to do politicians.
That's our next frankly, because
we know it's gonna be the same. Uh,
comics had more trauma.
Musicians had more substance
addiction. Yeah. Uh, and,
and we were able to show that overall
somebody who pursued being a celebrity was
more likely to have narcissistic
personality traits and
narcissistic injury and
trauma and substance abuse. Do we
sort of, we didn't publish that data.
We just published the narcissist and
things and it became international press.
He became, it was, it was
spread all over the world.
We ended up writing a book about it
called the mirror effect. And so, yes,
the point is somebody that
look up this book now,
it's called the mirror of fan and
someone that, I mean it's very, you know,
we wrote it in such a way that
was pumped for general consumption
of this industry that we're
in participate in. Yeah.
As in large part. Like, you know, it, it
is like the, the thing we wanted to do,
we do it, we do it for a
living. We enjoy doing it. Yeah.
But part of me always goes like this
overall might not be the healthiest well
business to be in.
We were able to show that it was
a bid to solve those traumas,
connection between the the,
and so,
so it's a bid to solve. It's, it's,
it's supposed to fill our emptiness,
supposed to fill what's wrong.
And of course it works when you're
up on stage and stuff doesn't work.
And then the other thing that my dad
always brings us up to me about like his,
his, uh, there's also college.
No, no, no. But he'll, you know,
his, his outside observation.
Yeah. Especially when,
like, when, what was the, here's
something when, when, when, uh,
there's like a suicide or, you know,
overdose or something like that.
He'll be like, you know, he
always talks about how, you know,
it's such a struggle to make it in this
business. Yeah. But he's like, man,
the struggle once you
has to be, right. So we started looking
at all that. And you've got to remember,
you know some people,
you know,
people who become actors and say have
you have no discernible skill other than
kind of acting. And they
put it all on this. Yes,
you're willing to risk
it all to be celebrity.
It's like that's a pretty heavy bat and
they don't back it up with any other
training or any other disciplines or
work or they just, I'm going to be this.
And that's, that sounds really dumb when
you break it to you. Right, right. Well,
but stupid decision.
There's a road and a discipline procedure
and we were also able to show that
celebrities that had skills were less
narcissistic. So like a cello player,
pianist, craft, craft,
professional craft journalism
salad on the street. That's right.
And so we were able to show that. So,
and again, the reality shows the worst.
Hey Matt, it's me. That's it. Just me.
You can just be the way now, right?
No psychological training. You can
pick that up from realities. People.
Hey guys,
I was on road rules
and the guys didn't come
up with that whole group,
came on our on Loveline of the TV show.
You were a part of that. I wish but no,
uh sorry. Um, but,
but the other thing is it doesn't fix
the emptiness and it also exposes people
to shame because there's a disconnect
between the adulation that they're getting
from the outside and how
they feel on the inside.
And then they are fearful that people
are going to see that inside stuff.
And then if they are really famous,
they have a group around them that
insulates them from consequences.
This all the time. Yeah. And so, so the,
they don't get more addiction
than anybody else will.
They do a little bit more but per our
data, but they are not worse addicts.
It's just,
it spirals out further because there's
no one there to bring them back.
Is there any,
cause I was thinking how unnatural it is
to become a really big celebrity is you
think especially about it. Anything else?
Think about that. They have no other job.
How would you have a real real,
when you see super super celebrities,
like there's almost always these weird
personality traits that you see in
quirks. You know like the Michael
Jacksons where you're like Jesus Christ,
but you also can't wrap your
head around how famous is,
I wonder if there's any healthy
way to approach prepare yourself.
Not really prepared because most
people aren't going to have it,
but like how to deal with that level of
celebrity. It just seems like it's so,
most people that I've met that are semi
saying had some other career before
really making it later. It seems
to be a health and later. Yeah.
I'm even thinking of like
Tom Jones and Julio Iglesias,
so when you meet them they just go,
hey man,
I was just a soccer player and then all
of a sudden this weird thing happened to
me. It's like, but I'm still that.
Just that guy like playing soccer and
I like singing and I was good and look
there. There's bewildered as anybody
as opposed to, hey man, this is me.
This is what it's all about.
Which is a different thing.
We talk about too with like with comedy,
really the best comics in the world,
um, are like at least 40
and usually late forties.
And I think it's a much healthier
example for comics to see that. Like,
cause it doesn't happen usually at
22. You know that Eddie Murphy? Yeah.
But like basically comics work for a long,
long time.
I think that prepares a lot
of them for that exposure.
A more grounded, it's a discipline.
Your bed, you've been, we're a crap.
And you're also treated like
shit for so many. Actually.
It's quite hard to get an ego from comedy.
It's very humbling.
But you're working on that new hour,
you're gonna eat shit after five minutes.
So it's this constant thing of,
of suffering really built into standup,
which is great.
Which is like,
you find it's more like blue collar
and then amongst entertainment,
but it's also the new rockstar in a
weird way for five years or so. Yeah.
It leads been like,
I'm very interesting.
I'll even though the millennials
are screwing that up,
I'd like to talk to you about that too.
Do you think our president is antisocial?
Uh, I think it's just straight
up. Narcissism isn't, well,
we have so many people we'd like
you to analyze, but I, you know,
it's the politics to me and,
and even just questions about what
are the right and wrong ways for it to
function stuff to me is so fantastically
complex. I just go, I, I don't,
I don't know. It's humoristic to think
I would know the right thing to do.
I started worrying about Trump
and I started thinking, okay,
this is probably where, well, where
else would we seen guys like this? Okay.
We'll Andrew Jackson for sure.
Very much.
It's a duck at Andrew Jackson was Yosemite
Sam. I mean, he was, oh, you're ready?
Think about him. He was nuts.
Yeah. I mean, it worked out okay.
And that's a good for it.
Some of the Indians and the
southern area of the United States,
but it worked for the country when we're
done. Okay. Uh, and I thought, oh my God,
Teddy Roosevelt was a malignant
narcissist. They and bipolars hell and,
Oh man,
he never took a meeting sitting down.
And you have to follow them through the
park or he marched through a park and
climb hills and stuff and everything was
outdoors and moving and shit and blah,
blah, blah. And I thought, well,
that he's my favorite president.
I so I don't know the narcissist bipolar
is good, bad. I have hell, I don't know.
That's scary. I, um, I, I didn't
consider this as a kid, you know,
as a kid, presidents are just kind of
like God's. Yeah. As I became an adult,
I remember one time this conversation
about presidents and personalities came up
and somebody said something
along the lines of,
can you imagine the ego
you would need just to run?
Yeah. Just to say, I wish to that, you
know, why did I do that? I promise.
I remember thinking about that and that
having that, having one of those like,
Aha affects where I was like,
Jesus, I've never considered that.
That they all have to be
pretty. Absolutely. Maybe Jimmy,
Jimmy Carter not, and he
didn't work. And it works good.
It didn't work so well in the office.
It's a greatest,
really think you're the shit.
And I have a weird preoccupation with
reading presidential biographies because I
just one day at a
similar kind of epiphany,
I was looking at the Pentagon had a
guy, the pennies, not just a profile.
It's a person. Yeah. And I know it's
something about how people work right now.
What happened to that guy?
His childhood, I need to know.
So I started reading and dark red like
20 Clip Lincoln biographies and I'm
reading grants biography right now, but
Chernow's new thing. So good. So, so,
oh my God,
what's that?
Lincoln severely depressive and well
does an interesting wrinkle in that. Yes,
he was, uh, he was sorta bipolar
maybe too, but, but he, uh,
really an interesting wrinkle if finally
started making sense to me, cause I,
yeah, all kind of fit together in my
head the way I know how people are.
I keep jumping out of you.
So, uh, a guy who wrote, uh, wrote a
book called the Lincoln marriage, uh,
discovered a whole trove of,
of letter correspondences between Abraham
Lincoln and a doctor in Springfield.
We started seeing before he married
Mary Todd and he found all these letters
were Lincoln was
convinced he had syphilis.
I think that's why he broke off
the first engage with Mary Todd.
He saw a prostitute,
became convinced there's all this syrup,
but he went by the river and is all this.
That's where the prostitutes hung out
and uh, became convinced he had syphilis,
dropped the marriage with Mary Todd.
This doctrine letters, reassured him,
take this mercury, you'll be fine. You
can go ahead and give it Mary Mercury's,
how they treat syphilis back.
They treated a lot of things well and,
and there's all this correspondence
going all the way into the White House.
He remains on the mercury most of
the way through his presidency.
Do you know what the main side effect
of Mercury is? Depression. Depression.
And I thought, oh, that's why he
had severe vegetative depression.
There's a story of him pulling a willy,
I think it was willy or tad
down the street in a wagon
down Pennsylvania Avenue.
And they said he,
they found him at the,
at the Capitol building still dragging
the wagon upside down with tad like a
mile up the street
and he was just going these
vegetative depression by the way,
that I feel like severely suicidal
at one point too. They, they uh,
what's acoustic? I used to sleep in
the same bed with a, I forget his name.
He had to go, Wah had put on
watch with him. But I'm sorry.
Another thing that I think you know,
I've always heard about and obviously
you get informed with these things,
you know,
little by little and more and more,
but especially since podcasts and
you start to hear from fans and P is,
I can't get over how at
least it appears to be,
how many people suffer from
depression? Oh, it's 50% of stuff.
Some sort of diagnosable. Hi, very common,
at least at a lifetime will
have a depressive. I had
depression, I had severe.
I kind of probably have
a tendency towards it.
I had panic and anxiety disorder and
all that bullshit and college. Terrible.
I'm okay. Yeah. Cause you can
go on despite these things.
They're treatable and they're part
of life. The thing is you got to,
I'm fearing now finally, and I was
a real advocate for this forever,
but now I'm thinking
we've over medicalized it.
We've overdone it now we're where you're
not allowed to solve these problems
through living and ordinary misery is no
longer an acceptable component of life.
Ordinary smile all the time.
Right. I should be happy.
Sigmund Freud when he arrived on
this continent was asked a question,
doctor [inaudible], what do you expect
to accomplish here in United States?
I said,
well,
I hope to be able to finally distinguish
between true mental illness and
ordinary misery. Then that's a great
quote because where's your misery?
Part of live are living.
Yeah, and we just,
we just don't tolerate that and you should
see real somber and sad. There's loss,
there's misery, there's anxiety. This
shit that stress. Life is stressful.
It is part of living. But I mean I, I
meant to say like when I brought it,
just that like the, I guess the amount
of the frequency with which it occurs,
the, the a number of people that
suffer from it, from podcasts,
I swear I see so many messages
that say like, you know,
I suffer from depression but like I,
I find some relief in listening to
podcast people. Right. All that,
that's great. That's it. I'd rather they
do that to take her medication. Yeah.
If you could do with that, that's, that's
overcoming ordinary that that's being,
you know, dis depressive. That's not a
major depressive episode. You know, and,
and again, people I think are not schooled
on the fact that they should expect,
feels down some,
exactly.
The life is suffering a lot and there's,
shit sounds the Hungarian,
but I do feel like eastern European
thing too, it's like we suffer,
we suffer, they, they take,
they take great pride.
I should look up Hungarian insults.
Oh creek cause of life.
We are,
we'll never eat and death is upon us as
their regular party and we love and we
make porn that is there. That's,
that's their main export. That's the
Paris support check, check, check.
Girls will come over all Hungarian honeys.
Um,
so we had this kind of
game we want to play. Okay.
So we have some classic,
we play a lot of,
usually we have a lot of quick,
we'll just play it at the top.
We play video, audio clips from all
over the Internet. People submit,
send in like you know,
watch. It's like just some,
some content to basically address.
Um,
well we were hoping that you would maybe
take a swing at is do you think the
person involved in the clip is a,
is taking drugs? Is it one a
youtube? No, it's not. Okay.
Or perhaps mentally ill. Perhaps both.
What do I think is going on here?
Why do I thinks going on here segment
before you have sex
that's going to be horny
for two or three hours.
Like you never been in your life.
Any of access to marijuana
too good.
We'd listen to me.
True. We'd alone can get you
really hornier than normal,
but it's been on drill.
Take about 10,
12,
Bynum girl before you want to have your
sexual fun with your partner or whatever
you do or masturbate.
All right,
so what do you think?
So I'm just looking at the environment.
They're out here. He's got his jacket
living in Versailles. So there's,
there's, there's like he's, and he's
sitting in an old, uh, sort of, uh,
angry grandpa recliner and he looks
like a young version of agriculture.
Angry grandpa.
They're younger version.
He has some Cop d and if you see
if you, you could see his, uh,
the upper chest. He was using
his accessory muscles to breathe,
which means it's got some product, lung
disease. Um, when he takes this balloon,
which I imagine is nitric oxide,
I feel like you have Steven Seagal,
a pill and it just look at it and
break it down. He does his pupils blow.
If you'd look at dilated pupils,
dilate, which night just can do that.
And he's also got stair,
which means you see the white
above the IRS come back every week.
So this is all when you see the
white above. But you know this, this,
when you see white above that's
drugs or hyperthyroidism.
It's about the only two things.
We'll do that with math
being them probable cause.
So this is now I'm putting and nitrous
in the same dude with the tobacco problem
because he's got emphysema. How does
10 to 12 Benadryl affects somebody?
Is that a good idea that
makes you agitated? That
actually goes the other way?
It could. It could delay ejaculation,
which is what he's talking about. Yeah.
I don't think he really understands his,
what he's talking about,
but that's what he's talking about.
You recommend somebody,
I would not recommend it because you
get something called anti-cholinergic
delirium from that where you
really can get very like delirious.
You get really well.
Some of the weirdest psychosis
I've seen a bit cynical and Miller
anti-cholinergic delirium
from drug overdoses really?
I mean they just get like,
they just get white and that could
be from Benadryl. I take a nap,
anticholinergic side effect dependent.
It's,
it's what anti-histamines
do in high doses.
The culinary check system gets plugged
in, right? So it's anticholinergic and,
and it's, it's a really
serious side effect. I mean,
you can get sick so you're get it. We
would never went to label anyone a legend.
I don't know this guy,
I don't know nothing about him,
but he put this video up and
I'm just analyzing when I seen,
I'm just guessing opinion. There's a
probability that maybe drugs are involved.
Yeah. There's a reason
why 10 to 12 Benadryl,
it'll make you agitated. Yeah. Which
I imagine too, which helps you.
Well that's what you want me to
finally have an excuse. And so
and, and so, uh, you know,
people think because too bad,
it just makes me more tired.
Maybe three it makes him for,
and then you got about four and
you're getting into trouble. I get,
I get exploding head from a two.
What's the 50 milligrams panics?
Floating head syndrome.
You've heard exploding head
exploding head is, you're, you're in,
you're asleep and all of a sudden
you get like this exploding sounded,
it wakes you up. Like somebody knocked
you on that really so weird. His thing.
Yeah. It's going to explode again. I
totally, by the way, not to be killing me.
Sorry. But I really thought you were
talking about your deck when you said
that an hour later when you fill it,
just kicking and smoke your weed, honey.
Wheat is the least of my concerns was like
millions and time. What is the,
we like billions of times better
from a professional standpoint. What
is the deal with weed? Like the deal?
Here's the thing. I mean like,
you know, we, we grew up in
this era of like, I mean,
when we were kids it was like, you know,
you better watch out the dare program.
It's still schedule one. People go to
prison. Schedule One was a bizarre,
it's bizarre. That's bizarre. You Go,
you know, like I'm saying like in the,
in recent years you had this whole
medical, yeah. You know, movement.
Unfortunately a sham, I'd rather just be
legalized. And then now recreational has,
has been evolved coming. Uh, so you,
so there's no medical value. Uh, no.
There's some, there's are some, but,
but that whole sham, yeah. Yeah.
Everybody's gotta have lights. I
never, eight years of my career,
I had never treated a single patient
without a marijuana prescription. So No.
You know, when you go in there
you and ask if you have addiction,
but treated for addiction before they
just, here's your marijuana prescription.
And so that's bad medicine. I just,
I just care that it's bad medicine.
I don't care that this medical marijuana,
it has some utility for some people.
I've recommended it for people. I just
recommended it last week for someone.
I'd much rather see somebody on
pot than, than opiates. Sure. Yeah.
And I think our laws are insane.
You know,
alcohol and tobacco are
good, right? Really good.
LSD shouldn't ever be touched
by human hands. Like what? Yeah,
it clearly has clinical
utility. I mean, end of life.
LSD may be very youthful and
cannabis is just cannabis. I mean,
why is that one day there'll be,
there will be problems and Colorado is
sort of founding and finding its way
through that. Um, but in terms of
also just significant problems,
adolescents care their hands,
people getting stroked,
getting addicted here and there. People
having an untoward side effects from it,
from, not very common, but
I've treated a lot of it a lot.
It's very difficult to treat. Is it
more, is it a psychological addiction?
Addiction is either you can stop
or here's what addiction is.
It's a biological disorder of the brain
where you cannot stop, you can't stop,
you're addicted, you can stop, you
have an addict, you're an addict.
If you can stop,
you're either not an addict or
earlier in your disease process we,
you still have control.
Please get control over it.
Don't let it get out of
control. Oh, okay. So you like,
you can also spot somebody in,
in,
during going down that path because
addiction is a spectrum disorder from,
you know, predisposed to
incipient, mild, moderate, severe
and then, and stage. Yeah,
cause it's interesting like with,
I mean I think we see it most probably
most people are familiar with like
alcoholism, alcohol. I think it's a little
clearer. Alcohol has the unfortunate,
the other category of the
binge intermittent alcoholic,
which is kind of a weird category that
Bert,
I'm not sure it's even a written anymore,
but he's,
he had sober October and all went well.
Yeah. I was competing with them know,
and he was very concerned that the
plane rides would be difficult.
But you know what, he, I knew he didn't
care cause he's, he and I talked about it.
He's in that more earlier stages of it.
He's not out of control.
I didn't say it earlier and it's
an early stage. I said earlier,
she still has some controlling. This is
what you should nip it in the bud though.
Yeah. You gotta be careful. Yeah. Why
did they consider alcoholism a disease?
Well, yeah. So,
so what is the disease you need to
define disease first before, you know,
I'll check the camera for you here.
So you,
you have to define disease
and then decide, oh, this,
this particular condition or disorder meet
criteria for disease. So have addicts.
It's cancer.
It's when the cells go nutty and Joe's,
so it's an abnormal physiology.
Cells go nuts.
I had no biophysiology but you
can't will yourself out of cancer,
but you can't go home early in the
stages, but later on you can't. Uh,
but keep going. So He'd say it's
abnormal physiology words, Everwell,
physiology come from, we're going to
reason our way through genetics. Genetics.
Is it strictly genetics,
genetics and environment interact to
give you an abnormal set of cell biology?
Right, right. Okay. And that cell by, how
do I know that cell biology is going on?
The abnormal biology,
the pathophysiology.
How do I know that happened out of I'm
a comedian combined. You can reason.
There's signs and symptoms.
There was signs and symptoms of
somebody like me comes in and goes,
those signs and symptoms
mean pathophysiology here
mean let's look at his jeans.
Let's look at his environment,
see how that occurred.
What are those signs and symptoms do
over time and breakdown or they grow,
they progress or their resolve or
they become product. They have,
they have a what's
called a natural history.
And then what does somebody like me try
to do it? Natural history. Well you,
you try to alter it. We tried to alter,
we tried to treat it, we do treatment.
So disease is a complex relationship
between the substrate and the environment
that results in an abnormal state of
physiology reflected in signs and symptoms
that follow a predictable pattern.
We call it natural history with a
predictable response to treatment. Well,
addiction fits that model perfectly.
I chat where people freak out is
where's the cancer? It's in your brain.
The cells are abnormally functioning in
your brain. The pathophysiology is there,
and we know a lot about it now and it's,
some of it's chronic so it doesn't
get better. And so it's always,
they're loaded up, ready to go if you
re expose yourself to the chemical.
And so it, and it goes. And
once you have real addiction,
I mean bonafide addiction,
volition has nothing to do with,
you can't choose anything
malicious, could be sideline,
not treatable.
At a certain point it's treatable,
but you have to get somebody in a place
where they can't use their volition,
where they're there, where they
start to understand that any thought,
any impulse and he,
any what we call stinking thinking
and he desire I have is my disease.
Cause it might the,
all the,
all the wonderful functions we have
rational prefrontal and all that stuff,
all those under the influence of distorted
motivation which is as opposed to
survive and thrive and
protect your family, it's use.
That becomes your sole motivation.
And that's a broken state of brain.
But can I get back back to,
we were talking about Bert,
I don't want to talk about,
let's talk about,
let's talk about bread but I don't want
to like you know, a bash them bash burst.
But my question about
someone like him is like,
isn't there like people will use him as
an example who like he's a late night
guy, he likes to have fun. He,
you know, he, he can party,
drink a budge but then he could
also, yes, yes. He does not have a,
what we would call a high biological
genetic burden. Right. Okay.
There are some people they
start and Kaboom, you go, I'm,
I'm reading this book on grant. Grant
had real deal alcoholism. He was like,
Andy Dick, I mean real
deal. When he would drink,
he would just go all the way to the mat
every time, every time. And he could not,
he couldn't do anything about it.
There are grades to this,
there are different biologies to it and
there's grades to, it has, it has it,
but he could be,
I mean from,
so that you can all end up in the
same place as the bad part. Birkin go.
I'm saying Burka go south, but he
could also be fine, right? Yeah, yeah.
He can live his whole life like this.
Does he go,
he can stay at this level for his
whole life. He could just, sure.
It doesn't have to progress particularly
takes periods of abstinence and stuff
like I was doing and he felt good
during that. Abstinence. Great.
And it was reinforcing to him so he
might have more periods like that. Yeah.
He felt great. It felt great.
It was, I mean, I think it
was healthy for everybody,
but even Joe Rogan was talking about
how he felt better when not smoking pot,
which is like, yes, dude. Right.
You can't take them no mind altering or
brain affected substance every day and
not have it affect something.
Plus we thought we did a
bunch of hot yoga classes,
so that also made us feel good.
Good. You know, we did 15 in a month.
Good at 90 minute classes. Yeah. Um, yeah.
So did you go on Joe's a think tank?
It's sensory deprivation and sensory
deprivation, but, but I mean like it was,
it was a fun, it was, I think, uh,
exercises and discipline are just healthy.
So like, even if you're not somebody that
goes, like, let's say you don't, like,
it wasn't hard for me to not drink for
a month, but it's still an exercise in,
in discipline.
So I,
I enjoy challenges and I like doing it is,
but I push back a little bit against
thinking about people or consume excess
alcohol is not being disciplined because
some of the most disciplined people I
know can still have a problem
over here with the alcohol. Again,
thinking of grant then grant stuff.
Sure. Super disciplined. But man,
if you got exposed, yeah, watch
out. Yeah. So and he would,
and he would spend long periods of time.
He was committed to the
essentially early Aa,
which were the temperance movements.
He actually signed temperates agreements
and stuff cause he knew he knew what
he's dealing with. Yeah. And
it's funny when people have
the real deal, alcoholism.
Yeah. They know. They know. They
know exactly what's going on. Yeah.
We think is going on here.
Hi Melanie. And I'm Scottio with
ecstatic hearts. Tantra. Oh,
I was just wanting to share that. There
are many ways to, or NASA, oh Geez.
You don't actually have to be having sex.
You can orgasm just from hugging.
Ah,
ah,
AH,
drugs, delusional, delusional,
mental illness. Well let's,
let's go three data.
We analyze the people again,
here's the day he was
not having an Oregon.
He was pretending she might've
been having an orgasm.
I don't know how she got there.
He might have been holding a vibrator
or something. Everybody knows. Um,
but first of all, we need to teach her
both how to look into a camera. Yeah.
That's a very disconcerting with,
I'm looking off camera like that and
it's not like they're bringing everybody,
somebody they're way off camera.
And then in a like a convention
center, like this has been some sort
of tantric sex meeting, which is gross.
It's gross. Weird. Right? It's weird, but
he looks very happy that they're there.
Yeah. She looks full of Shit.
Basically full of shit stare.
Yes. Like I, to me,
it's just full of shit.
He's just happy to be there.
He's like, yes. I mean, yeah,
he just wants to get laid.
That's right.
If you find a path to get laid and it,
and like you hadn't been laid in a while.
This is taking that pat, you're a male,
are you kidding?
But that's really what's happening is
she's into it and then he's just using
this coming along. So she's
delusional, right about this horseshit.
Is it just to get attention? Is that, is
that what we're doing at the comm? Hugs,
I'm guessing was called come hug
by the way. I am guessing that,
again, it's some sort of
weird gathering. The thing,
maybe it's her friend that runs it and
she's just a good example of how her
friends or maybe she runs it.
Maybe she's trying to commercial and the
other thing is like you draw people in,
you get attention, people sign up and
then they're like, I keep hugging.
I'm not coming though what's going on?
And they're like,
then you feel like you're not doing it
right. You've got to pay for another,
another set,
another conference,
or you start through the perfect scam
or they start blaming yourself.
Pretend that you're coming.
Then you are part of the delusion,
such bullshit. I mean, look
at this fucking coming,
look at his face. He's cracking up
and he's like, really? He's just,
and you know like he's this,
his neck muscles contractions laughing.
That's total bullshit.
It's total bullshit.
We cannot three of us kind of standard.
If somebody else's happy,
you can't stand it.
I don't like it either.
I it bothers me when people can
get joyful about things like that.
I'd love to hear your thoughts on this
one. I can't wait. God's love the fuck.
Fuck. Oh, you're a hot black
guy and you want to fuck me.
If you want to move then you can move.
Fuck the fuck the lot man.
Free Food,
free rent and everything else, man. He
hasn't GL man. Oh boy. Hold on. Hold on.
Jail, homeless or rum or
thug. Want to come move in.
Frankenmuth you too man. Free Rent.
You can lease in a cake. Fuck me. Piss.
Somebody beat me. Oh Man. I know you
seen me. My come over today. Try it out.
Try it out, man. I just get sad. I mean,
first of all, I go dark. The
circles are run at the eyes. Look,
well it was the biggest draw.
Slept in a month and then I just
smell math. I can smell that.
Yeah. Well the first time we
play is interesting. I said,
you know the funny thing about
this play this over and over again.
This is a regular clip,
not worried about your soul's down.
Forget is we're ruined.
I know, I see that he really, I'm
going to bring up my questionnaire
but this, I was like, you know,
just us some part of every man's brain
that has wanted to like express these
feelings like fuck me.
But I'm saying for someone to actually
pull out a camera and going to be this
disconnected, all of it. This was somebody
who was severely beaten as a child.
That's just all I see is just
abuse, abuse, abuse. Again,
to try to solve it or whatever. Whatever
our brain does, it makes us do that.
What's with the ball at his head?
It's very dark.
It's not his spot on analysis.
It made this sad for me now and yeah,
that's why I could never go to strip
clubs and things cause I like all these
women are
supposed to be empowering.
That's what they say is
you guys don't get it
pissed. Let me try it out. Fuck man.
I'm looking at the hardcore guys want to,
Julie and I wanting to live with it.
I'm a hot white trash. Go do your five
bucks. People just send this into.
So that's nice.
I'm so glad I'm talking to your fans.
Very nice.
Laughter.
At
least a varsity level.
You don't have to give me college.
What do they call it?
Fort with the big level football though.
Division One Asian one.
Don't give me a division one varsity
highschool bar. Ready for that.
There's so much to show you.
I'm so glad you're here because we clips.
We laugh.
I laugh.
I'm glad
I get to see this. Do you know what
the door shut? Yeah, it's dead.
It's deeply troubling. I
told, I told her this before,
every time I go,
I've met porn stars immediately.
Like I don't see them as sexual beings
like you, cause you, you make it.
What's going on? So I go, I
mean, I totally understand.
Did you see the sex rehab shirt?
We did.
So Jenny Ketchum,
penny flame
flame is now just graduated from
social work as an MSW at University of
Washington. Maybe getting
a phd. She's amazing.
She's getting married,
pregnant. She is phenomenal.
I ask a only if it's like,
like a public thing.
I would say I'm trying to say about
the patients. Yeah. About,
about her or if it's not known or public,
then I'm not, I can't tell
you if it's not, but like uh,
so was she traumatized we,
he's talking about,
or everyone's trauma came out of the show,
but for some reason people either
watch it or didn't get amplify.
There were specified enough. I mean like
Jeff Conway is trauma was so profound,
so unbelievable and ritualistic
and people are like,
I wonder what's wrong with Jeff?
It's like you didn't hear him talking
about he was dragged into a child porn
ring and he was beaten.
Yeah.
I feel like every one
of them I don't treat.
I always tell people if you have bad
enough addictions that you need to see me
as a hundred percent probability
of childhood trauma. Really? Yeah,
a hundred percent now I'm not saying
that all addiction has childhood trauma.
I'm saying if it's bad enough that
you need to come to somebody like me,
it's this childhood trauma. And it's
bad Jenny and horrible stuff. Well,
that's what I learned. Watching
celebrity rehab. I think that's what I,
right when I started getting a
therapy is there was that trend of,
I mean we discussed this on your podcast.
Person would go in and drew and be like,
how was your childhood? It was fine. Yeah.
Oh yeah. Except for the part that my dad
beat the shit out of me and my mom. No, I,
I'd have to go. I'd have to
go. I'd have to go. We'll,
do you have any physical abuse? No. I go,
I go. Did anybody ever discipline you?
Well, like anybody, I got
this and then I go. Okay, good
discipline. So they hit you?
Yes. Oh, of course. I needed it. I
everybody like anybody. I needed it. I go,
did anybody ever pick up an object and
hit you buy belts and did they use the
buckle end? You all? Of
course. The BUCHLA. Oh yeah.
It was one time it was a bad oh
yeah. And the hatchet. Oh yeah.
And the bow and arrow.
And then it just starts and they think
of that is normative and they needed it.
That's how they get it and
they internalize it like I
was serving at that which
is,
which is the child feels so powerless
that they flip it into an causing this.
I'm making this happen to me
because I need it cause I'm bad.
So Ron and daddy can't be bad now
because I need them to survive.
That's right and what happens is those
unresolved feelings of trauma turn into
not like you just said,
sometimes addiction,
sometimes they manifest what later in
life is something but can be treated. Yes.
Right, right. That's the
big highlight of this.
I thought you were to tell us something
specific. I just want people to feel,
I don't want people to feel
hopeless listening. Oh Shit,
I was hit and am I screwed.
My fundamentally,
the way I think about,
the simplest way I look at it is that
you need closeness of other humans to
develop the mechanism
for emotional regulation.
That emotions if you've been
traumatized or to trow prolonged,
too intensive to negative and the way
that is healed is in closeness with
another human. Unfortunately
when you've been traumatized,
you don't trust other humans anymore and
you exit the frame of closeness and you
never go back until somebody in therapy
finds their way back in with you and
that person that holds that frame
and just listens to you and racks.
How hard is it?
Cause this is one of the things I think
maybe I don't know that a lot of like
the amateur audience watching
a show like that would,
would have difficulty processing is the
the level of distrust from some of the
people that you're treating. All of them.
I feel like though like aren't they?
Isn't it hard to break
down? Yes. Truth from this,
how it turns me into a
gigantic mind reader. It does.
I got to the point, I'm a little
out of practice with it right now,
but where I could,
I could just trust whatever came out
of my mouth without thinking about it.
You can trust whatever comes up. When I
could, when I was really skilled at this,
I'm a little bit rusty right now,
but, but I, I would just, I would,
I would do what's called,
I would listen with my whole body.
I would not listen to what they're saying
cause I know what they're saying is
all bullshit. And I was just
listening to the whole body.
If I felt something or heard
something or smelled something,
I would immediately go, I immediately
go, hang on. I'm just, I'm not sure if,
does this have meaning to you?
I was smelling like,
Oh that's my dad was always making bacon
when he'd fucking throw grease on me
and burned me out there. Okay, well
I just happen to smell some bake.
I don't know why because people, it's so,
it's all compartmentalized and I'm
literally picking up on disavow,
disconnected parts of the south that
are crying out for attention but,
or disconnect from that human consciously.
But it's there all the time creating
all kinds of commercial turmoil in that
person. And I sort of, they sort of,
they pick it up like that fried
thing of your unconscious reading.
Another person. Yes, yes. That's
what it is. But I, but I think,
but I think it's that sort of a,
it's not a evolved enough
way of thinking about it.
I really feel like there's
so much information going
back and forth between two
bodies in proximity.
It's really not just the brain,
it's our entire central nervous system,
including our autonomic system.
And we just, we just can, we send
stuff back and forth to people.
And if you really listen, if you
learn to really train yourself, and I,
and I also trained myself to be able to
know when people were not telling me the
truth and I would just go, that's
very nice, but you're full of shit.
Stop it please. And I could just trust
it when that would come out of my mouth.
And, and most of the time,
most of the time they would
go, oh, how'd you know? Yeah.
And they'd go, I don't even
know what to bull shit anymore,
but I'm glad you helped me.
I need to know what I'm,
cause I still have worked with
some master manipulator. Oh my God.
And I had been manipulated and I've been
had and whatever, but, but you, but,
but I can, if I do feel
it, I can just go, Eh,
you want to work in the or not
shut up. Reminds me of, by the way,
this I mean to say the skill set
you're talking about is watching like
detectives in um,
not a lot different.
And then you see like we used to watch
a lot of the first 48, uh, and um,
there is certain detectives that that
was the hook of like that was you get
excited about you.
Like she is amazing.
She would like, there was this
one, yeah, Sergeant Mason,
I think in a, in Tennessee.
I still remember her name and she would
go in and the guy be like, I didn't,
I didn't do anything. I wasn't there.
And she had this ability to connect.
Yeah. And five minutes later you just
see. Yeah. And then they would confess.
It was amazing. Did you see behind
Hutter? Yes. I'll watch the whole thing.
You got some of that stuff came out in
that too. Oh, it's fantastic idea. Yeah.
Yeah. Fantastic. I remember even when he
met that first guy, he was like, well,
how'd you feel about it? It didn't feel
right. Well there you go. Listen to this.
You're were. We're perfect instruments.
We really are. And if you've been injured,
that perfection gets
expressed in crazy ways.
You like women that repeatedly
go for abusive guys.
If you're attracted to the guy, definitely
that's going to be an abusive guy.
If you have that path,
do you have that pattern?
If you were abused as a child and you
have that power as adult and you will,
you think that's a great guy?
Guaranteed that guy's gonna be,
I know he looks nothing like an ax.
Nothing like the other ones. Still.
That's going to be some guy
guarantee like I've been, you know,
we've all have interactions with
like bad dudes. You feel it.
You feel site like Predator dudes. You
know what I mean? Guys? You're like,
this doesn't feel right right away. You
feel like sometimes you can, I don't know.
It could be out in public. You can be
introduced to someone and you'd be like,
I don't want anything to 3%.
Yeah, good times, Huh? Yeah.
That's what I have to watch.
Videos.
Oh, the women practice on the
egg. What did the men do? Okay,
the Amanda first thing,
the have to practicing that
we call sharpening the knife.
Okay.
The whole key.
So we caught a egg,
the baby oil oil and you put the in and
now put up eat peanuts to warm up in the
cold winter. You warm them
up, you get a hot power, okay?
And you'll make it a one.
The what?
The hand you put your hands and then
make sure order blood flow on your penis.
Okay, now you'd get the penis out.
You pull the skin. A lot of people,
they never succumb.
The horse had skin to skin and you get
the oil in the hand and your hand going
ids to rob, rob, rob, rob,
especially on the Klan Penis,
50 time Ras,
because you make them strong
and not sensitive to the time.
Once a [inaudible] 50 times left side.
Phil town from 50 times,
50 times I three feet. Okay.
How often am I doing this?
You have to do every day until you
can control every day time consuming.
Extremely sharp knife. Okay. All right.
You're done traveling at night.
There's the number one. Number two,
you have to learn how to
contracting the prostate gland.
When men,
it's accolation the pressure of the
circulation if from the prospect and
contracting.
Okay.
Exercising exercise one and four people
have positive land stolen up a problem.
This one who solved the problem and now
you do it until you feel okay. Awesome.
Oh really? Yes. Okay. I call orgasm
without ejaculation, right? Yeah.
So you feel, so you see when
you do, when, when you get it,
it's very quick to two times.
You can
yep.
When you squeeze it all
guests, I'm coming up. Oh good.
So what's happening here with him?
He's a teacher. He's a tantric guy.
A D two pieces, a lot of things
actually. What else? Well, he,
he also teaches women, um, you know,
to rub their nipples and um, and
I think it puts an egg, well,
he size up your vagina,
muscles are loose,
then your door is open and all the
energy leaks out of your vagina.
So you need reminds.
Is he a yoga guy?
A tantric guy that's been around
for a minute. Like we, we, after we,
this was the first thing we were exposed
to about him and then we found what's
his at this, I can't figure
out what you guys think. He's
ty. Ty. Yeah. And then um,
then he did like a female one in the
same interview and then somebody found a
like a 25, 35 year old clip
of him and he's been doing,
this is like your kidneys are Tega do
testicles. You got rubbed your back. Like,
oh my God.
So wait,
you said that's not right when you
said the orgasm is in the prostate,
prostate doesn't move. He did the, the
pelvic floor musculature contracts.
But that's not through your prostate.
The seminal vesicles are what are holding
the semen, the prostate, just to gland.
That's sort of slowly producing fluid
and story at the seminal vascular. It's,
it's not really any other activity. Mm
hmm. And what about sharpening the knife?
Is that an effective feel
about times? Rob, Rob, rob?
I think the whole point of this
was about control. Yes. Yes.
And that's why it sounds
her a tantric life. Yeah.
But then like 300 times 300 strokes a day.
All I kept thinking was 300
times two seconds, the chart,
because it's about 600 seconds or so. Who
the fuck has time to do this every day?
And I'm worried about that person's soul.
Again,
I'm worried about the souls of all these
people that you're showing me because
their priorities don't seem right.
If that's what the practice by with doing
every day there's better mindfulness
then sharpening the knife. So
I'm saying okay, not a priority.
Seen better mindful practices.
There's a possibility that
this guy is a bit delusional.
Although as a no, I don't think this
guy is mentally ill. I don't think.
You don't think he has? No, no.
I just think he's a Weirdo facing
straight up here though. That's the thing.
There's a thing as evil, bad weirdo
that they exist. Oh, I'll raise you one.
Oh Jesus.
And when we got to Varsity,
uh oh no.
Oh,
I just want to let you know there
is really the two my dex or release,
yet they're on a shrimp
Scampi boat and uh,
like they are like getting
turned into Lasagna. So, um,
I need your help getting a
rescue boat over there and,
and a day they really need your help
getting rescued. So could you, uh,
please,
please say yes.
What did she say? She's talking to talking
to Hillary. She's blogging to Hitler.
He's asking for the fear.
She's asking him for a rescue boat.
Two friends that were returned
to the Scampi. Gabby boat.
They're trying to get into
the zone yet. Okay. So,
but Hitler is the guy she's talking to
that she sings happy birthday to again,
I always leader of the third one.
I always like to look at the environment
and I look at all that stuff,
but she's a really big fan of
that. A one direction. Yeah.
Reminds me of people that
set up, you know, sort of
shrines and things to people.
They go and try to murder them. It
looks like that kind of thing. Yeah.
And when you, if you close your eyes and
they'll look at a radio listener voice,
she sounds like she's about six years old,
which is an interesting thing that happens
in severe trauma survivors is they've,
their voice stops, talks about this
on a and the sex stuff. Second,
maybe we should, uh, have
a new title for our cash
and if, um, no laughing matter now if,
and if she's not just sort of being
bullshitting, she's severely psychotic.
When you close your eyes for a
second, close your eyes and that what
he's wanted of you to hear, Hey Hitler.
So I pushed that. Hey Healer. No. Oh No.
Hey Him. So severely psychotic.
Yeah, because of the eyes and no,
I don't see it in their face. Right.
It's just what she's talking about. Oh,
so disorganized and almost,
it almost sounds delirious.
Like she's like, well,
why don't we lighten things up a little
bit. Good. Yeah. Um, varsity, low
old. Are Your thoughts on this?
Not Somebody talking,
but just to see like what you find funny,
what you don't find funny and steel
reaction. And then maybe you can,
he's going to zoom right through
there. No, he's just sent me
car.
Oh No.
Okay. Why? Except I know
what that injury is.
That's bad.
That kind of a correction really bad.
I mean it's funny,
but it's not funny.
Could be dealt with in a few minutes.
Thank you. Okay, so let us clue
you in on what the debate is.
Crush injuries like that. Those are common
and they, they ungloved they'll, oh,
it's just the worst.
Worst.
Often the leg will just split
open and ungloved and Tara,
the skin comes off entirely.
And then depending on how
bad the crushes, you know,
whether or not their kidneys fail because
their muscles crushed and going into
their blood system and how bad the
blood supply is cut off and how much
orthopedic injury there is
there. Yeah. It's just those
are catastrophes. People often amputees.
Yeah. Right. And that's really funny,
right Tom? No, but let me be fair.
Let's be fair about something.
So I've always had and
I've admitted to it.
I think the way I deal with with
physical injuries to people should laugh.
I laugh. Yeah, and I've,
and I've done it for 30
well she thinks I'm psychotic. No, I
think it's a red flag too. I had a nurse,
remember Sasha.
Sasha would laugh in the
most horrible situation.
She was all of a sudden started giggling.
There's nothing she could
do about it and she was,
she's a great nurse and
really compassionate,
but she had this weird nervous thing when
when things got really rough and said
terrible things start happening,
she break out like full laughter.
I was like socially and find that clip.
So funny when people are like,
he's a second path later,
we see it in front of him because I've
watched the clip several times and we've
had other guests on and I can't laugh
because I have left, said how funny it is.
What's called empathy.
It's funny if it were the three stooges,
the whole,
the whole problem is,
it's one thing that bothers me about
physical slapstick humor is you.
You believe that that's just funny.
Or if somebody gets hit in the head.
It's just funny, funny, mild
head injuries. Fuck people
up for six months. Yeah.
Yeah. One of Moe's or just
the fingers in the eyes.
Of course one of Mo's box
on the head would would be
six months of trouble and I,
and it's, it is funny when it's
the three stooges, Laurel and hardy
in this case.
What's funny also is that his reaction,
I think also because it's foreign, like
you don't understand what he's saying.
Yeah, you can. You can be, there's
some distance you can get from it.
You get distance from it. It's a,
it's an almost comical reaction.
So there was a quality of the reaction
that was like, oh my God, that's funny.
And that was like, oh my
God, that was really a pin.
A pending pending against the wall.
I remember when I worked,
I worked a construction one summer in
high school and this guy had a sewn in a
like morphine drip pack for
his neck and I was like worst.
I go like, why do you have that? And he
started telling me like very seriously,
he was on this site and they were removing
a bathtub from the third floor and it,
it fell out from the, the, the
lift and it crushed his neck.
I laughed so, so hard,
les. I love that. Well,
he was just looking at me and then he got,
he realized that he started telling me
all these other injuries stories and then
he got to the point where he'd be like,
ah,
I just remember you're going to love this
one. So he would do it to entertain me.
Like one time it was on the site
and I broke my arm doing this.
And I've always found
that's how I process.
How can we bring the guy around with you
all the time? I mean, it just, it just,
I don't know why you should become an
orthopedist. He would never stop laughing.
I laugh all the time.
Wait, so why do we do that?
Because I laugh at things that
are inappropriate as well. Well,
you're now you're asking me
what's the nature of humor
and laughter, which is a really
complicated question, but his,
his reaction to that man hurting,
being harmed and possibly dying is,
is laughter.
Um,
and that is numbers that evil exists
on the spectrum of EOP on mind hunter,
is that what you're saying?
I'm not sure it's that kind of problem,
but, oh, and what about this drew on?
Something's really wrong with me. Oh
yes. He's dark, dark sided. Dark side.
What about the fact that my husband
Paul, incredibly compassionate. Okay.
When I'm falling asleep at night, he'll
watch TV and he'll watch. It's all,
if you look at his Netflix Queue, it's
murder, murder, murder, psychopath,
serial killer, drew. They make all those
shows just for me. Yeah. Isn't that neat?
Yeah. They go like really deep into post
production for me. We'll talk later. Yeah.
Yeah. What's going on? So just for
you, it's just me. I've talked to them.
They've said it was just
for you on orders, just for
meeting all that starts 48.
It's just all me likes that. Should I
be concerned? I think I got to go down,
but he's such a gentle, yeah. The
thing is he would never hurt a fly.
Yeah, exactly. What'd you do as a kid?
Were you twisting rabbits next and
all the people, I do it now. Let's
see if I can really stock, you know,
God, pick someone and I
go fallen you. Oh my God.
You gotta get to know their habits when I
go to work. Okay. Anyways, anyways, yeah.
Here's another one that's not
like those other ones. I swear.
But I really want your opinion
on this and then, yeah,
he didn't want my opinion. All the
other ones. No, no, no. I'm saying like,
this is interesting one,
I think seriously. Okay.
Sweden is the most food thinking
country in the world when it comes to
questioning gender.
The gender neutral Pronoun Hen is
now commonly used by most Swedes,
so that's just a little intel beginning,
beginning.
This is Nikos Drum on how this Nico,
Nico is two and a half,
almost five and a half.
Mika and Nico were both assigned
male at birth and this family,
the sex you were born with does
not dictate your gender identity.
So then, so we're giving you
just a little context for this.
We use key for them.
Sometimes it's next and it depends,
you know,
because in Sweden we have hen the
gender neutral pronoun in Swedish.
I think Mika has always said when
I've asked it's been she or Ken,
uh,
changing pronouns in book
instead of it always being mama,
we say Mama and mark par.
What's the matter Sweetie
Yak [inaudible] it's so dark.
So just to give you the full thing,
what,
what did the next clip is also
what I want you to weigh in on.
There's this family there in
Sweden. Um, you understand that,
that they were talking about the pronouns
here and then these very young kids
are,
uh, how they're getting
different, um, hormones.
No,
they're just daily being given the option
to choose pronouns and it switching
over to a half and five year
olds or they're being asked, hey,
what would you like me to call you?
Okay, that's a pond. And they ended up,
that's not something I always have to say,
but it would be good to
note to Dave for the film,
The Sky Hone Ella him. Just Mika. Okay.
So the kid answered,
um, just by name. Yes.
Do you think that there's anything,
uh,
odd to asking?
Very small children their gender pronouns?
I don't know, cause it was, it's
unusual. We're not used to that,
but you would have to be really studied,
have to see what the outcomes are. Right.
I'm a little concerned with the
biological reassignments. Uh,
the crazy American Academy of Pediatrics
just came out strongly against it.
Um, is that being done? Oh
yeah. Wait, what do you mean
reassignments? They're born,
they're being, if they say, I feel
like a girl today around, I've,
even though a boy,
you better get on those hormones.
We're right away keep the
three year old and uh,
the j the concerning and we don't even
know the full medical consequences of
that either yet. So it's all, but people
are doing that. Oh yeah. My crazy butt.
But I, this part I, I'm sort of
agnostic about. Yeah. It's like,
it's like maybe it'll be, I dunno.
Maybe would be good. Okay. I,
I'm more worried with the way
this guy's treating his children.
It does not feel very
connected or empathic. Yeah.
It feels very,
yeah.
Tutorial.
Everything's very like weird and formal.
I mean babies just because
the camera's there, I don't
know. Right, right. Oh yeah.
But it would not feel comfortable being
his, was he dad or mom? What does it, oh,
you would not feel comfortable
having him as my mopar. Right.
I mean feel weird if you're that kid,
that's where she's like, Hey, shut up.
Calming Mocha. Yeah. Stop
asking me comfortable.
Do you think something mental
is going on with this type?
Um,
don't understand like why you bitches
and people is May this because I say I'm
black and Andrea to Dakar.
Sam Let,
but at the end of the day, what
is the race anyways? Your family.
Cause like we outlined, we are here
on this world's supposed to be equal.
It just in the past people
was messed up and stuff.
Oh honey,
what's going on here?
I feel so angry at our educational system.
Sometimes I really get
angry substance stuff.
I don't see anything metal.
Why? Nothing mental health wise,
other than the little angry, but,
but just like, come on everybody.
Let's go back to school. Wait, let's
be able to function in society. Yeah.
You want your
daughter to stay at a fuck bitch.
Why would you with somebody you don't
know this real sad and obviously you can
see I'm not ugly bitch in my head.
Go down. Might be a little fat.
Never claim to be skinny.
Is there a per people just listening?
These are two back to back. White girls.
I love these two girls. Yeah,
they're pretty, pretty entertaining.
Why don't you start talking like that?
I'm trying. I can't do the accident.
She's still going
and I don't see Nancy
anyway,
but as soon as I get it for you.
Yeah. You know he'll, he'll talk about
it being raised around that. Oh really?
Oh yeah. Oh yeah. Louisiana.
He does not have good feelings about
what was going on there. Really? Yeah.
It was pretty good.
Stuff's going to get me in trouble with
the racial stuff. Tommy, what's
that word that you taught me?
Where you choose your race? Oh,
trans rate. That's interest. That's,
people are like saying like, like it'd be
like me saying, you know is I was born.
I know, but you see, but I'm actually
Filipino. Yeah. Identify with fillers.
Filipino mental illness or is that a,
what's going on with you?
You've tried to get me how much trouble
you've tried to get me one podcast.
These people, what's happening?
Is this a societal homeless?
This is a social phenomenon. This is not,
it is not a real health issue. Got You.
So this is just the time.
This is what's in the ethers.
Yes.
If you want to move to that fuck the Oh,
that,
oh, there's one last guy. This
guy has been like a big deal.
This poor man. Right. But there's just
one guy we want you to weigh in on.
Just, he just uh, he's got a
dinner waiting for him at home.
Walking down the street,
just working on a song. Okay.
Yeah. Machines. But then
machines was g six g
notice anything there is everything seemed
normal or no? Trying to make my rough,
trying to talk to Shawn with
machines,
with them machines.
I just feel, I feel sad. I
feel sad. It makes me sad.
What part of it?
Just that we're failing people
so miserably and it's done.
He made a note.
It's called crazy, isn't it? Well, who
would I go? I'll drop that birthday party.
Crazy. Isn't it crazy? Isn't it?
Drop that first drop that
first got the not crazy.
Isn't it crazy?
Isn't topped up first. How crazy.
Isn't it innocent. Innocent.
Innocent.
Is it great?
Juggalo okay. He would
be, we'll be fine there.
He'll be fine amongst his peers.
Wow. There it is. Normative,
somewhat normative behavior is engaged.
Even the junk clothes for five
rob with us, but he will like,
he will make a good juggler. Okay.
You know you're amazing. Amazing you.
You got your spidey senses back.
So now would you say this is mental
illness or an educational failure?
It's a juggle. Osis. Did
I go jogging? Holy Shit.
I was, I almost went to the
Juggalo conveyed whether
they call it the gathering.
Yeah. I want to go to the gathering just
to see what's, what's going on there.
I got to show you how many
people are so interesting.
I want you to treat them my very fun.
Can you treat them and mass?
Can you open up a booth at the juggle?
Okay.
Well the price people warned me off going
cause they said it'd be too scary that
I would get hurt. I think that's
a good idea. That's a good,
I really wanted to go though. I
really did. This gentleman is just,
he's a of low is a juggler.
It's just, it's a cultural,
it's just an expression. Expression.
No problems. Okay. He's not angry.
Oh yeah. Yeah. He's socially, like I said,
I got sad, but to know there's a place,
a home,
even for him amongst the Juggalos,
I mean that felt pretty good about this.
Hope for that was just different.
I think we're traumatizing.
Dr. Drill another one.
I'm in love with this. This is just
good comedy, man. Well, I'm saying like,
do you think, is there anything to
doing that is they're like, well,
should I be concerned about her?
Well, yeah, that's trauma, right?
Fart videos for money. Come on for
money. She gets paid for that. Of course.
God is great.
I mean seriously like seriously.
This is man,
you can do this too.
Okay.
There's a reason.
I
mean there's people that do this.
Is there something that there are people
that didn't play it over and over again?
The other guests on pipes. Well I'm
saying are you're saying, I'm just saying,
I'm just saying see there's suddenly all
kinds of pictures and she's been abused.
Right. Stepdad. I'm in love with
her too. She's a very sweet girl.
This is the best thing ever.
This is now. That's just funny.
I just enjoy that. Thank you. What about
[inaudible], why is that funny? Oh,
cause it's does this type of,
cause you have so like there's still
many tells that you're keyed in on. Yeah.
I feel like, cause you're like, you
know, you look at the eye. Yeah.
Do you think that this voice go property?
Yes.
She made me do copious
amounts of cocaine with her
and I thought my heart was
going to stop. Yeah, that's it.
She made me do copious amounts of cocaine
with her and the point I thought my
heart was going to stop. That's
it. She told me to calm down.
Oh,
gave me a drink.
Okay.
And I don't know it was in the drink,
but I blacked out.
Okay.
She had both of my legs
over her shoulders and I'm,
she was numb sucking my asshole.
Like there's no tomorrow
numb sucking. What is it? I'm sorry.
I tried to find it. I tried to
get away, but I was restrained.
She told me that I liked it.
You probably,
Jay told me not to worry because she
used the good jelly. The shmuck says,
I mean,
is this something we don't know who this,
nobody's paid me to confess this now,
and I've kept it under wraps for all
these years because I knew that no one
would believe me.
No one will believe that Hillary Clinton.
Oh my asshole.
Oh my gosh. But doesn't his, his.
I feel like there's something going on
and tell him the truth. I can't tell.
I can't tell what he's
not telling the truth.
I don't know what's up with [inaudible].
Ryan sickler. It's very funny comedian.
Oh, is it? No, no, no,
no. I thought it was him.
I'm looking for my favorite picture
here for you guys and the Juggalos. Yes,
my check a little picture.
I'm going to find it.
They could really use you
in that community. Yeah.
Maybe I just don't want them
to kill me if I show up. No,
you think that this love pops.
We've had a bit of a rest time now for
some triangle or assaulting and Templeton
few pop place seems really simple because
most people just get huddle hobbling
around and going more for,
for buck buck.
But it's really so much more complicated.
But that guy started this
pup play training in New
Zealand writing training and
he's got all these guys into it there
and he was, um, basically like, oh,
it's a fun, get together. You
know, like, well first he was like,
just a bunch of guys enjoying each other's
company and then later it's like we
also ejaculate in each other's face. And
yeah, that was a big secret, you know,
after we, so, so that's sorta like the
furbies furries. Yeah.
On that video there.
It's all like, you know, on the up,
like it's like we just hang out and I
treat them like dogs and then we found
videos of him online in a different
light where he was basically like,
run your finger along
new. Correct. If your ass,
you don't need to figure your home.
You don't want to come back with shit
on your finger. No, you don't want that.
Yeah.
But he was instructing people in a much
more graphic way when it wasn't a news
piece. Of course he didn't want to.
Yeah. What's that? Oh there we go.
Oh my gosh. Violent J and Shaggy. So drew,
show me a picture tonight on love line.
You had these two guys on level
repeatedly. The insane clown posse.
These guys are many times ICP,
they're my buddies.
I've heard them on a stern before they,
they're seen front and they're fun.
Guys like come to studio like this.
They never seen anywhere without either
a Mexican wrestling masks mask or that a
comic upon ever. They've never
been seen is a lot of work. Yeah,
that does seem like a lot of work.
Do they do it themselves and imagine the
guy with the hockey mask wearing that
makeup that then he starts to make
sense, does it, right, right, right.
That's what he was looking at you,
what's your take on,
you would look like shaggy or you know,
people make fun of Juggalos a lot
and like ICP and all this stuff.
But then I love them though,
bring about how business savvy
these guys are with this, you know,
the brilliant and,
and there,
there's a whole philosophy of stuff
and it's hard to argue with them.
I mean they really are conditioning
guys and it is positive, right?
They're all about this.
A little bit too much aggression
and violence when they gather, but,
but other than that, I have no
quarrels. All right, well we'll look,
we want you to go home and have salmon.
I want to see support for videos. Oh,
okay. Right. Oh my gosh.
Your mom's house. We got 'em.
You asked for it. Yeah. Oh,
same girl. No. Do you think?
Do you think she really does this or
somebody playing with a video or sound
effects over is a rooster
in the background?
Do you know who you chat is the best
idea? You think? Do people pay for this?
That's the thing that we're trying to
figure out. Is it sexual? Yes. Yes.
It's super get off on this.
It's not just comedy. It up.
A while ago a guy wrote
in and he was like, well,
the whole thing is seeing a
pretty girl do the dirty thing.
That's what he gets off on a dirty thing.
Well,
you know why the rest of us just
laugh? I don't know. Some cake farts.
Who has,
come on,
let me see if I can
definitely had a bad child.
I mean you don't find on the Internet
cause things were good and your childhood,
you know, there's, there's a high degree
of secondary enforcement. What's that?
She gets paid a lot probably to do,
it may just be one of those things.
It's a hundred dollars a
hundred dollars, I think. Uh,
Susan says she's tired and she made
a crappy dinner. Oh, that'd be like,
I'm glad I'm not there. Should I put
her on the show? Get on the phone. Yeah,
we're watching fart videos.
Do you think something's going on?
Um,
we're gonna show you the king real quick.
[inaudible]
sorry. Sorry. Sorry. Sorry.
Please analyze this guy.
We're really curious about him.
We get it. She's texting me. What
she has to front is drives me crazy.
It drives me crazy too, is don't you
want to murder your spouse sometimes? No.
I want to kill you and you don't
answer and I want to talk to you,
but he didn't just complete a
text to you and then not answer.
Oh my God. Please. Come on. Come
on. Susan. Come out of this.
She's missing such good
material. Talk about she loves
fart humor. Really, really?
No, she, she does not get it at all. Do
you fart in front of each other? Sure,
sure.
He's called the king ass rep over there.
How about the guidance during the days,
Joe? The farther here. This
guy blows that guy away, dude.
Yeah, it's really good. It's a real,
we've tried contacting him. Oh my God,
you won't come on our show.
I know. I guess it's identity
is a secret. Yeah. Yeah.
Well, no, no. Shows his space.
Yeah. In this video, does
he respond to your emails?
No. I mean, look, look, we've offered
him money. Look, it's all it's all about,
oh my God. You guys live in this
world. Yeah. Yeah. Hi, Susan.
You're on the podcast. You
didn't tell him that. Hey,
you didn't tell me that your mom's
house is just these two sitting around
watching late baby.
Okay.
I'll look at the king asked
river on the voice. Oh,
she's watching the voice. Oh. Um hmm.
Whether you didn't tell me that your moms,
hang on,
you didn't tell me your mom's house is
just these two sitting around watching
park videos,
which you want to think
mark video. Yeah. Yeah.
Uh, no. Uh, we have files saved. We,
yes. How did you, how
did you know about that?
Yeah.
Well these two have made
an art form of that,
that they apparently study it
like the Zapruder tapes. Yeah.
Yes. I was, my first
exposure was recently. Yes.
We were both like in
disbelief. Thank you. No,
this was just watching women fart online
and we were like, yeah. What? Yeah,
it's a special lane.
Thankfully I had been pre my,
my hymen had been ruptured prior to
getting here. I might've been shot
your version of art,
art videos.
Um, so many, but I just want to tell you
I'll hear the it but she can't hear it.
Right.
That's the guy though.
Aw. Yeah. This is the guy at Barton,
his dog. That's animal abuse. Right.
In our world. Our dog's abuse. US.
Of course the dog enjoys it. Is it
really considered animal abuse? You,
as soon as I called you to
tell you what I'm still doing,
so I'll get home soon as I can deed
your crappy dinner as you said.
Yeah.
I'm sorry about that.
It's fine. I'm sure we miss
you as soon as we could be here
this time.
It was terrible.
Oh, I'm sorry. But listen, they miss
you too. I'm sad you didn't come.
Oh, I know. Thank you for
saying, man, I wish I could have
do all the, do all the plugs. Gifts. I
isn't, wait, wait, Tom, sorry to Susan.
How great. How great is
Drew's body? Amazing. Yeah.
Yeah. And if we were talking about
it, you know, it's really cool. Oh,
okay. This just in case your
kids are listening. No, no, no.
You have your prostate
removed. No Demon. Right.
Those very closely.
Very clean and that must be nice.
The changes. No Muss, no fuss.
Oh No.
Is that not PC for your show him?
Oh
are you fucking
started? Very nice. But it
goes down a rabbit hole and
you were not in the leader,
so that's so fun.
That's the best line of the night.
He'll give all the plugs on there.
Forget. I'll remember to do it. Go ahead.
No, before I, after I
bleached my butthole,
make sure you listen to this podcast the
doctors do about forest or my counter
would just depending on what kind of mood
I'm in. The dark [inaudible] podcast,
Adam Admin, drew podcast and
weekly infusion. Oh, it of course.
Calling out with Susan Penske,
which I'm resurrecting. Okay.
Oh, I'm not sure you want this
crowd over there, but okay.
They've already been on the show,
honey.
No, no, not these two.
I mean the people that did find them
amusing in their current mom's house.
Okay. All right. Well I'll be home
soon enough. All right. Love you too.
Bye Bye. Just, it was beautiful. Yeah.
The your show, what's it called?
Sorry, I've forgotten the you live.
How do you have time to do all of
this shit? What the hell doing?
I'm just to crank them out. So you're like
a pro podcast or, I mean, I'm, I'm like,
it was a serious workaholic though.
So everything seems easy to me since
those days. Yeah. This is the fighter,
but he also does gluttony videos.
Three fucking Oh beef and shut her
sandwiches. Slop with fucking manager.
He's in Brooklyn too.
Full complete disappointment.
You don't like to eat anymore.
It's hard to watch. Yeah, but he,
but I love how fucked up people are.
Very
weird. Right? There's,
there's also videos.
He gets out a bunch of this food
and farts on it and then he said,
I want, I want, I'm not interested in
him. I mentioned that. Who's watching him?
Yeah. Like who we've brought him
to a lot of people. I mean a lot.
Dual. Yeah. Yeah. It makes
you want to throw out.
Do you think this is like a fetish
thing? Yes. All this is off of it. Yeah.
Any, anything that's sexual that shouldn't
be sexual, you know what I mean? Why?
Why do you think gluttony? How
does that turn someone on? I, I've,
I don't,
not an expert in this area,
but I've always had the sense that it
was something to do with being force fed
as a child or something.
It was two gratifying or
maybe the breastfeeding was
done at two an aggressive
away or something. So they always feel
like they're overwhelmed by it. Yeah.
Just do fart videos and then a,
then he started doing the glider evolved
as an artist. Yeah. He really did evolve.
Paid for these things, right?
I think so. But you know,
we've never really found his pay stuff
more fucking gluttony already know.
Yeah. Gaining leading community.
Yeah.
I'm wondering if it's my channel,
gluttonous slob and go to
the pig out checkout button.
I'm wondering if it's so we know
you guys asked me for cash is
gay or straight gay? There's no
women that are interested. No, no.
I'm other heterosexual men. It's all,
everything weird is mad. Let's face it.
A heterosexual men or straight or gay man.
Maybe that's why he won't answer US genes.
I think because we reached out to him so
many times and I think he needs to keep
his business in tact. I think it's gay
guys that are in there that he, uh,
he goes also by, I fart in
your face. That's a, but he,
we really, this is him here. This is like
him and his hard drives to the Florida,
our dresser to Fart on, you know,
and he would just post these
videos.
Camera Quality.
Yeah.
God,
Oh, everyone has their
own towels. You know,
there's a big scandal about those five
videos with him was that he'd handle,
but people didn't believe
they were genuine. He was
shooting heroin to himself.
Okay. There will still be genuine
in a weird way. Well, yeah. Well,
let me ask you this. Medically speaking,
I mean, is that really possible?
What that guy's doing or is that fake?
It's possible is that the bacteria
can produce a lot of gas. Right?
They split that I tried to do is waste.
Are you writing this down then and
so the methane that's produced by the
bacteria,
it can be high volume and if he holds
it in for periods of time and then films
it when it's time to go,
yeah, I can see where it'd be.
Probably probably knows what to give him,
feed himself to get the optimal
and sometimes swallowing air.
Sometimes people will swap out of air
and some guys could suck in air. Yeah,
they could actually suck it.
Like will the party,
it's kind of a trick,
a parlor trick in not a real thing.
So it's like inserting
air. Well, let's be fair.
What is it you actually
want from this guy? I mean,
does it really matter
how it got to that point?
Does that violate your sensibilities,
your delicate sensibilities?
The Geneva Convention on Fart has to
be pure bacterial Beth production.
We'll have no above air for below.
The judges will rule for me.
I want him to eat that. Rbs. Yeah, but
if it's swallowing air as part of it,
his gas production,
some people the air goes through.
And why not give them that if he has
that talent? I mean, I, I understand.
Like I'm just saying, the judges say,
I feel like they couldn't be the judge.
I feel like the committee
would want to review this.
I feel took worthy of worthy
of a throwing the flag I want.
I want to official review. Yeah. I have
another very scientific, oh my God.
I don't know if I could take anymore,
I'm sorry.
My mother used to tell me she used to,
I used to Fart a lot and when
sometimes I'd complain about the farts.
She would say that you should
be grateful for the farts farts.
Push the shutouts. Now is that true? That
puts the farts out as far as and shit or
a center sort of disconnected phenomena.
Yeah. There's sort of, this
can be a little connected,
but they're obviously, there's
some connection there, but they,
they're independent.
They're not just still push the farts out.
They eat a shit. We'll a fart. We'll come
out with the shit, but this shit is dope.
Yeah. And the, she said the
FARC push the shit right.
And it's a little different and the
farts just come out. They just forget.
There's no causal relationship.
Not really. I mean,
it may give you more of a sense of a
desire to depart, studying and being,
did I ever think I'd be on this show?
Any show talking about this and you never,
I not, that's not something I expected.
If he's talking about, I thought we,
I thought your wife was really smart and
I thought we'd talk about Kierkegaard,
Kierkegaard, Thomas Aquinas,
Kierkegaard on top of it.
Well,
I took a leap of faith by coming on
this show and I'm here to work here.
I was wrong because it has
done so much work out there.
It's for, is required to get
here. But, uh, I think, uh,
Heidegger was a little close to the proper
analysis of the extensional phonology
round. You're the best
man. Thanks for coming on.
Thank you for letting us torture you
with these plants. Are we really done?
I have a weird sort of like
desire to continue. Oh,
I'll get the weird like weird,
like I feel attached to all this.
I've traumatized traumatic attachment,
trauma bonding.
You're going to associate beards with
this for a long time and it's stalking
behavior and I'm not going to know
when to leave or go. Give me one more.
Give you one more. Okay. Gimme
a gimme a high grade? No, no.
Violent medical injury stuff that I'm
to be thinking about the surgical suites
without the dad excitement.
The trans.
What about one of your other guests?
Have extra,
had extraordinary reactions
to extraordinary high level
reactions to two guests
that should be able to take it. Is this
thing, I don't know. Is this one of them?
Hold on.
I want one.
They did eventually meet Ken who
shares her sexual preference. Oh,
not this Belgian until I was 29 years old.
That was to follow him.
No, no. Zolal file. Yeah, I know.
Shit. I'm doing it on the fly.
But then bomber. What about the,
what about the transition?
Savannah Trans Canada highway? No,
that's not weird enough. No. You know,
my radio partner and Mike Catherwood
sends me where it's stuff all the time.
He goes on the dark web and he's very
fascinated with a dire people that
diarrhea on each other. I, I buy,
I need to connect Taran breakup clearly.
Uh, they diarrhea on each other.
It's a sexual thing.
You can't really do it on each other.
Only one person gets to be the
receiver. Oh, I got to go. Well for you,
I've got to go look for you to see it.
It's really awful.
The vomit every time and he
finds great gleer delight.
People have a strong reaction
to this. Ah, here we go. Tom,
your moms and your, my son and I if
falling in love with him. Oh, he said,
are you really? I said, yes, I
am. He's thinking, you know what?
I was scared to let you know too. I am
too. We're both consenting adults. If,
if it comes down the way, operate it,
it's just like it is a whole phenomenon
and everything.
Everything's fine and a way.
There's a woman I ended up in interviewing
several times who was in recovery
from this.
And so she can talk about what the
delusion is like when you're in it and how
people get into that and
how they get out of it.
So you're saying because of
the separation, the, the bond
was, it's distorted. Yeah.
It gets all fucked up. So He'd be,
how do you develop a, a romantic,
you don't see them as a maternal figure.
It's just a way.
It's just all you get sexualized
inappropriately and stuff.
So should you be able to marry your
mom? Know, cause, cause whenever,
but everyone's just like
the gays though. What, what?
That's what that guy says. You saw that.
But he goes, it's just like the gays.
What are you shooting? Yeah. Yeah.
It's like if we're both adults
[inaudible] and producing kids that close,
you can do that. But uh, I, you know,
I have a question about
government overreach too.
We should get involved
with that at all. Yeah, no,
I heard in a college that you can
have sex with your eyes forward. No,
not accurate. This is University of San
Francisco. Okay. A lesser school. Yeah.
And I,
I,
I was told that you can have offspring
with your cousin that you won't have a,
you can with your siblings
are and with your mom. But it,
but the risk of trouble
is they're really hot.
The lessor lessor because as you get
further and further away, it's less,
our cousins is not that big a risk.
Right.
Like royalty used to marry the Egyptian
royalty. You were married their kids.
Oh yeah. That's pretty good. Brothers and
sisters and things they did. Horrible,
horrible, nasty. Hell.
That's a very bizarro
the kilometer marker.
7,128 and this is where
I believe with a 90%,
uh,
no mic,
that 95% chance that this is in fact the
very place where that Trans Canada paid
dates.
Last section.
Oh yeah. Right here. Yeah, that's me.
That's me
there. And he's based, he's
really good. He Really,
oh, one more time. Down the middle
said the guy with the double rainbows.
Yes. But that guy was on dry six.
Oh. Oh, oh. Oh. This is a downhill sucks.
Unfortunately, this is drugs so
weird. We never thought about,
oh why didn't we think of drugs? What?
What kind of drugs are we talking about?
Louie? Second doubt. Yeah. Yeah.
Ladies and gentlemen,
your Trans Canada highway.
It's odd, right? I mean it's a lot.
Can I take a shower before I leave?
But it's oddly mesmerizing. Yes. All
of this salary. Mesmerizing. Huh?
You guys are good. Good job.
Is that Charlie
out?
[inaudible]
calm down layer per Musteal.
It's just soup. Moose
suit. Yeah, she's looking,
she's a watching this boat race and the
guy falls in the water and then she goes
from like, you know like you
hear like fuck cause you,
he fell in to keep asking them
to come over for moose soup does.
She's got later for them.
What do you think she looks like drew?
Like just on the voice. Hmm.
Granny from Beverly hillbillies.
That's pretty accurate.
What does she actually look like?
A granny from nailed it.
Oh yeah. You guys come down here
after I got moose soup and everything.
All right. You guys are doing
good. It's not the rights of to,
Hey,
I got you on video.
Did we get to see her?
She blows them all later in a different
video or a floor guy. Yeah, that's great.
No, no Tom, no, this, she really
look like the granted, you know,
we never say no. No, no, she does. Cheryl
Tiegs she doesn't no, no, no. She looks,
she looks like she's a mass bill.
Yeah.
Like she has most of all time. Jesus. All
right, I'm ready to go. Alright. Okay.
I'm dying over here. Is done. Tapped out,
tapped out. This has been awesome. Thanks.
I wish I had,
I wish I had had a clip to play.
They would top everything I was
trying to, you know, get me a winter.
It tells this video.
I'm actually pretty amazed at how not
phased you are by all of this. I mean,
you have seen it all.
I have seen it all. Trust me, I eat
mostly what I, when I see Albert behavior,
I'm either sort of Zig
Wadley, you know, sort of,
uh,
intrigued or I feel sad.
Those are the two feelings I get are like,
like really?
People do that and then I get sad
cause I know how fucked up that you're
sad it, but you're also empathetic.
Think we should go on strike
against, come uh, come stripe,
keep going.
I'm only going to swallow the calm of
a man or put on my by the come of a man
who's willing to touch
it or kiss me afterward.
She just felt like she's good for
her and she plays a little Chopin and
Beethoven. Oh yeah. Yeah.
That we'll attach this calm.
I won't either
bolts that.
She's my favorite.
She's probably still was piano teachers.
So it's a, it's extraordinary stuff people
put on line is that, that's our whole,
that's our whole show. But I mean
the stuff, the stuff they send you,
I'm impressed. I got to get Kathy when
in your, in your my radio partner in, in,
in your world.
Let's do it.
Cause he goes on the dark web and he's
a genius at finding horrible stuff. Oh,
please hook us up. Please
look us up. Okay. Yeah.
I have to just constantly
erases his texts. Just
fucking, let's do a group text.
One last thing,
just as a societal question.
You're a smart guy and you seem to
analyze stuff and where it's all going.
I do feel like this lack of shame that
we're now experiencing in our culture,
like people posting, come
strike videos, et cetera.
There used to be an element of like,
hey, this is private versus public. Oh,
that's all gone. Right. What are the
consequences of that psychologically as I,
uh,
society,
I,
I'm less worried about the,
the mechanism of this manifesting as much
as it is that people are running at it
and using it all the time. In other
words, they have no personal boundaries.
So this is the perfect place
for them to be boundless.
It's not the technology's fault.
That's an internal phone.
I didn't know what you guys are putting
on line, but I'm going to be looking,
I'm imagining it's not going
to be this kind of stuff. Yeah.
Hoping Tom Left. No. Okay.
Uh, and so it, it's, you know, we live in
a time with people who have been abused.
Their body boundaries have been violated.
They have no personal boundaries.
They've come from no fan, unstructured
family systems. And you know, that's,
this is it. And shame is shame
is the sort of, either they're,
they're overcome by shame or
they're totally avoidant of shame.
Those are sort of the two
versions we have today.
And avoidant shame avoidance are
narcissists assess exactly shame of,
Oh yeah, there's this refuse to
feel ashamed of anything. Yeah.
There's a real famous guy right now
when you get to see him every day. No,
but you know, really was like,
that was Clinton. Oh yeah.
He was very slippery with shame.
Right. And we're just be, you know,
be these horrible,
shameful things. It just
depends what it is in super narcissists,
Uber narcissist and that I'm surprised
that has not come crashing down more.
Yeah. So that's like, there's a push for
it. More like it's coming now. It's, it's,
it's starting to comment
and it's been the,
I always thought that was
the most extraordinary
exploitation of an underlying,
you know, just extraordinary
in a, in a place of business.
Can you imagine that the person in the
highest level of authority take advantage
of the person at the lowest
level? Hmm. Yeah. That guy would,
that CEO would go to jail,
right?
Not only be in a civil problem and if
his wife came out and then tried to abuse
the intern, she'd be in trouble
too. It's like, yes, I get it.
It's just not okay. But I guess, yeah,
because like we said at the
beginning to be a president,
you can't be all that healthy. Yeah,
for sure. Oh, it's for the record.
Drew thought that the car
crusher video was funny,
so that's just something off the record.
I muted both of your mics,
muted both of your mics. Yes, he did.
Yes, he did. This is Tom signing off.
You said it was funny.
I said there's a funny Pete.
Part of it is stuff I that for the
three stooges to be very funny,
if it were in the context of fiction,
a lot of people have sat there
and said it was funny. By the way,
I understand why.
I understand why,
but I know the reality is people are
psychotic, right? No, no, no, no.
I could see why somebody would say,
that's funny. Let's put it this way.
First of all, they were not female. They
were all male, which for sure, right?
Maybe we should. We find violence
funny women. It's all w you know,
three stooges humor,
because they're dumber.
Why is the defining line between men and
women is three students. Humor stupid.
Why women just looks at it.
It's cause it's stupid because we
create life and you guys destroy it.
When you're a mother and you make life.
The thought is is pretty
much we don't kill.
We just destroy her name or
different name. Yeah, it's my child.
I think we'll wait to, your son gets
older. Oh God. Oh my God. You'll see it.
You will see it. The destructive nature.
Oh wait, your kid turns 40 I can't wait.
I want to be here to
do a podcast with you.
You'll think it's great coming back
to come back. Yeah, let's schedule it.
Let's schedule it. All right. All
right. All right. Thank you so much.
I'll talk to you later.
Thank you.
Do you know what that is?
But those are
the song made a busy stores love you to
everybody.
There you go.
I love you.